[Applause]
but we have to get down to business
we're in North Carolina and they talk
business but I want to just thank
everybody for being here wonderful crowd
oh look up there look at all those
people thank you very much thank you and
thank you to been a special guy he was
very tough you know in the campaign
trail I had to fight him for a long time
he wouldn't go away he doesn't give up
and he's smart and he's good and he was
a great a great surgeon and I don't gave
that up for politics I've got to talk to
you about that right where is he sitting
where is he
Matt you're gonna talk to you about that
Liv have to explain I think he's
probably regretting that no he's doing
an incredible job a incredible job we
are been housing Hayes done a job like
few people have done it but wonderful to
be here with the incredible men and
women who are restoring prosperity
that's what you're doing
rebuilding hope and delivering
opportunity to those who need it most
together we're making our country
stronger than ever before we are doing
numbers that you wouldn't even believe
nobody would have thought it was
possible this morning the brand new jobs
numbers came in we smashed expectations
and created 225 thousand new jobs last
month 225,000 they were thinking maybe a
hundred maybe 105 I was watching all the
geniuses this morning on television what
do you think it's gotta be it's gonna be
110 to 25 pretty good right 225,000 for
last month
that's only last five unemployment
claims in North Carolina are down 30%
since the election and have fallen to
their lowest level ever recorded pretty
good
and we're here in Charlotte to expand
and grow this unprecedented economic
momentum that we have going all over the
country you're having the best year
you've ever had in this state by far
today we're launching a brand new
nationwide campaign to revitalize
underserved cities and towns all across
America it's called opportunity now
opportunity now it's a big deal and you
know we did with Tim Scott Opportunity
Zones and they're the hottest thing
you've seen it's the money is pouring in
Tim from South Carolina and the money is
anybody from South Carolina yeah say
hello to Tim he really did he came to my
office with this idea and I said sounds
good but those things traditionally have
not worked and Opportunity Zones are
amazing what's happened tremendous
amounts of money being put into areas
that hadn't seen money for decades and
decades anyway so what we're doing is
because we aren't waiting for tomorrow
and we aren't deferring people's dreams
to another day with relentless optimism
we're taking action right now and I mean
right now to create a future of dignity
and security for all gonna be an
incredible situation you'll say and we
believe in no American left behind
that's what it's all about no American
left behind in the coming months my
administration will hold summits just
like this one in cities across the
country working closely with community
leaders workers entrepreneurs employers
and faithful eaters our great faith
leaders so many great people I've met
you know we got rid of the Jensen
amendment so they can speak their will
to make sure that every citizen can join
in America's unparalleled success and
every community can take part in
America's extraordinary rise together
we're building the most inclusive
economy and the most inclusive society
ever to exist we're fighting for great
jobs great education save homes and a
limitless future for our people we're
lifting high citizens of every race
religion color and Creed we are all
Americans and we are all made equal by
the hand of Almighty God you know that
very well
joining us today is Small Business
Administrator Jovita Carranza who is
helping to lead this groundbreaking
effort along with secretary Carson
Jovita where's Joe here Jonah
Thank You Jovi the great job thanks also
to the many great members of Congress
that you have with us and these are
warriors these aren't like these people
have been fighting hard you mind if I
take them am I allowed to take a couple
of seconds and introduce him I call him
warriors senators and Congress men and
women but they've been incredible you
saw what happened
it was the impeachment hoax and now
that's a thing of the past so now they
have a failed impeachment hoax they can
put that on they can put that on their
resume
[Applause]
that doesn't go good in a that's a
failed hoax everybody want every one of
the them have to put it right on that
resume was a fix except when it got up
to Congress were we had 197 to nothing
our Republicans hung in and our senators
were incredible they were really
incredible same kind of a thing and
man's here who's really become a friend
over the last year and a half and we had
a good relationship but we sort of
disagreed on a couple of minor policies
and that's okay of course I won't put up
with it for long Tom tell us he's been a
great friend
it's true no we had we just had some
disagreements at the beginning and now
at the last year year and a half boy
it's been it's been good it's been good
and you have something on sanctuary
cities that's gonna be incredible
they've got one of the big hands that I
know nobody listened to the speech the
other night but it got one of the big
hand we got to push that right so Tom
thank you and thank you for your support
it was great your vote and everything
else we have some congressmen I've
gotten to know him well it's like we're
we were in the trenches together
representative Ted bud thanks that good
job a man I campaigned with and he was
fantastic he handled pressure very well
they they said you couldn't win and he
won by a lot we did a little bit of a
rally for two guys that are very special
one of them is Dan Bishop dan thank you
Dan he campaigned and he didn't choke
there was no choke he had a lot of
pressure but he ended up one body like
five or six points wasn't it was like
boring that evening you were winning by
too much I thought it was gonna be a lot
closer than that right Richard Hudson
another one right Richard great great
job
everybody knows Mark Walker thanks mark
another one of those two that I talked
about recently
you know CNN and they all had their vans
that were already because they thought
would have two losses and they go out
and say Trump had a terrible night but
they both won and this guy was pretty
even and I think he won by 28 points
right it was like Gregg Murphy right he
won by a lot they both won by a lot a
man that I've gotten to know too well
I love his wife I mean his wife she was
with me before he was with me I have to
say it but he came along very quickly
long time ago right and she would go out
with women for Trump the buses ship
buses all over the place right Deb where
is she where's that Devin oh well I know
them cuz they followed me around a
little bit right they are incredible
they are incredible how many of you come
to how many rallies of you this isn't a
rally you know this it's a serious deal
how many rallies would you say cuz up a
lot and we have a lot of fun thank you
very much John Mark Meadows everybody
great guy a man who is without question
the greatest name in politics I said if
I had his name I would have been
president at least 10 years sooner
Patrick McHenry best name in power a
woman who's much tougher than any of
these people she doesn't stop right mark
she doesn't stop but she's great we love
her Virginia Foxx a very popular guy who
wins elections by a lot he's a
tremendous asset to Congress and a
tremendous friend Ralph Norman thank you
we call him landslide Ralph as he wins
by a lot William Timmons thank you
great job great job and a man whose son
I probably like even more than him Allen
what a job Allen's done Joe Wilson is
tough and smart and he is there all the
time and his son is just like them
his son is better than him I think right
and he doesn't mind you know I have a
lot of fathers that they don't like it
when I say that I've had some please
don't say that my son is better they say
you're not a good father he's a great
father and he's proud of his son his
sons fantastic and he's fantastic and
thank you very much thanks Joe
so we're honored to be joined by North
Carolina lieutenant governor Dan forests
wolves
big future big future you got to get rid
of the sanctuary city Dan you're gonna
be able to do that I think a lot of
people want to get rid of them plenty of
people in California want to get rid of
them believe me it's something we have
many others state and local leaders from
all across North Carolina we're thrilled
to have you all here and you're the ones
that really know best and we are we're
spending a lot of time in the state will
be coming here Lewis is around someplace
where's Lewis Lewis - joy thank you very
much and I appreciate it we'll be coming
here a lot and we're way up in the polls
but you know what I say I pretend one
point down everywhere somebody said how
you doing I said well one point down
everywhere but we're way up that's what
they tell me
way up in North Carolina way up in South
Carolina way way up in South Carolina
Ralph's way way up so anyway so we just
assume it's always good I always say it
pretend you one point down that way you
work your ass off right we have to do
that because this is the most important
election coming up this election is I
used to say the other and the other you
know the other is the other 2016 was
incredible but you see what's going on
you see what's happening on the other
side we want to take everything away
they want to destroy everything we've
built we've got the most successful
country in our history they want to take
it away not gonna happen it's not gonna
happen
as I said in my State of the Union
address earlier this week our nation is
in the midst of the single greatest
comeback that we've ever had that's a
comeback we were doing poorly you know
if you remember goes all the way back
for years I heard that China will take
over as the largest economy in the world
in 2019 I kept hearing that I hated it
because I said have I run 20 19 s not so
far away we are so far ahead we are so
far ahead now we became a rocket ship
take it in billions and billions and
billions and tariffs giving a lot of it
to our farmers and different people that
were targeted now we have a deal with
China I just spoke to President Xi last
night and you know we're working on the
problem
[Music]
show me you got harder to verify mention
what anyone who have been sickened by
the virus or seen loved ones fall ill I
want to emphasize how grateful we are to
those responding to the outbreak in
China and around the world as I said
last week we are working as quickly as
possible on the many unanswered
questions about this virus that includes
exactly how it spreads how deadly it is
whether it's common